your morning routine has to be on point  as I said in the top of this video  successful people don't wake up and say  yes oh my gosh what a day I'm gonna take  over this is gonna be amazing I woke up  and I was tired I don't remember what  day it is and I got lines in my face and  I'm struggling to get out of bed right  everybody wakes up the same way don't  judge yourself and feel like you suck  because you woke up and you were tired  and didn't feel super motivated to go  off and crush your day right that's  everybody that's me that's Brandon  burchard That's Tony Robbins it's Oprah  Winfrey everybody the difference is the  routine to set you up for success